ما الذي اوصل الامور الى هذا المستوى من
التوتر
في فرنسا
الاكراد الجاريه الكرديه والذين هم
مرتبطون بحزب العمال الكردستاني
[موسيقى]
اذا فبالتالي هناك غضب
الشديد ضد الشرطه الفرنسيه التي لم تستطع
توفير الحمايه لهؤلاء الناس
السلطات
في تعاملها مع مثل هذه الاحداث استهداف
الاقليات الجاليات الاجنبيات في فرنسا
السلطات الفرنسيه التي لم تقم كما يقول
المحتجون والمتظاهرون الاكراد اليوم
بحمايتهم بعد كل
الاحداث التي استهدفتهم في السابق ومقتل
نشطاء ومن جهه ثانيه ربما مقاربتها في وصف
ما جرى لهم امس قرب المركز الثقافي الكردي
بالقول انه
هجوم ذو دوافع عنصريه
هناك
دوافع ولكن بالنسبه لي هذا الشخص هل
الاستخبارات
الى النظر في معلومات كثيره لكي نتوصل الى
هذه النتيجه